it's a new and exciting thing about
amazing spider-man is pretty much
everything we've pretty much really done
anything every every single aspect of
the game has been reworked so somebody
that has played our past games for
example spider-man shattered dimensions
will basically see that we've reworked
every single aspect of it manhattan and
the free-roaming experience is
completely new the visual style is we
have to rework large parts of our engine
just to be able to throw what you've
gotten scream and probably most
importantly you're bringing a completely
new and innovative feature called the
web rush which will give players players
and then present level of control over
spider-man well what's so new about the
web swing actually is the is probably
the camera because one of the of the
thing that we really wanted to nail this
time was the notion of feeling like you
actually are spider-man the notion of
being spider-man in past games just the
way that the camera the distance of the
of the camera actually made you feel
almost like you were when you were
controlling a puppet kind of thing you
know but you were not you were not
spider-man yourself so by making the
camera much closer to the action and
some time like almost over the shoulder
it makes you feel much more connected
you're not looking at somebody having
fun you're the one having fun so when
you jump down a building you have this
incredible vertigo effect this feeling
of as you get to the near the street and
just web swing above car level it gives
you an incredible sensation that that
you've never been able to have before
well the combat is something that that
we've we've taken a new approach
something that's much more fluid much
much more grounded approach as well so
you're going to be able to build to move
from one enemy to the next and we've
given you all sort of tools including
your web shooters but also you moves
that we call signature moves so as you
move from one enemy to the next without
getting hurt and you build your combos
tree you're going to be able to take
them out and again base dynamically
based on your environment you're going
to troll them on a ceiling wet weather
there
sometimes you're going to web them on
the floor so many times it will be
thrown on a wall and that that creates
an incredible super dynamic choreography
if you want in any combat situation
you